hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica I just
had the scariest moment in all my time
in subnautica I was trying to load my
shave over in the experimental build I'm
now in the stable build I'll tell you
why in just a moment I was trying to
load up my shave and it would not load
it would hang and then the game would
crash and then I try that again I went
back to stable I went back to
experimental I I edited my save file
information I deleted files in my save I
copied it obviously did a backup of it
and I was about ready to give up I was
about ready to untilled on this [ __ ] and
started over and I was committed I even
recorded a bit where I was showing you
guys that a crash and I was going on
this big long rambling speech about how
I was going to take the long way around
because it's what it felt was right
because I didn't want to cheat I did not
want to cheat even if I had to start
over again and play for 20 more hours
just to get back to this point here I
was about to do that and then I then I
looked up just one more thing and that
was changing the via the the the date
the build date in my save file and going
back to the stable version and trying to
load it up there and it worked and I'm
here and I'm here and it worked and I
don't have to waste 20 hours of my life
getting back to this point here so that
catches you up on the hell that I've
just been through for the past hour and
a half so let's get back to the game
shall we alright so I know for a fact
that the next alien facility is not open
yet it's not available it does not exist
in the game the outside does and we'll
go see that in a bit I believe it's way
way way deep down but we'll see that in
a bit but for right now we got to
explore the the very last remnants of
what's in here because we have a blue
alien artifact and I imagine my theory
is that the blue alien artifact is
probably what's going to open the
primary research facility which is the
deepest facility in the whole alien
spectrum
of facilities this is the thermal power
plant which powers everything that the
aliens have used create even the war
pers this place powers it all through
wireless energy and that's really cool
concept I mean it's not totally foreign
we have it I think I mentioned that
before but super cool ideas it's all
powered in one hub now if there's a way
I don't know if any of you guys told me
I got comments from last time I'll read
them in just a second but uh I don't
know if there's um no way to get that
portal in this place open because that
is a portal that is one of the gateways
but I just don't know if it ties back to
a gateway in another location and if it
does that might mean I have to activate
it from there first but that doesn't
make a lot of sense because why would
you have a cheap way just to go down it
makes more sense if you have a way to go
back up so I'm gonna get back in mr.
Fisher who rose from the dead my hands
okay there we go good alright so I'm
going to explore the rest of this place
and hopefully find some more secrets
about this and maybe find a way to
activate you know that whole deal wow
this ceiling is a lot lower than I
remember it being in fact this whole
place seems slightly different than I
remember it being but then again it
might just be the horrors that I
experienced just a little bit ago so
this is a gateway I've seen this before
I know this before this is definitely a
gateway so if there's a way to activate
it it's gotta be in here it would have
to be in here there's definitely not
going to be anything else around ah okay
so right here I had to look it up I was
looking around the room for a bit and
then I just want to make sure it was
possible in the future plans section
that says the precursor teleporter in
the thermal power generator will be
hooked up to the teleporter in the
quarantine enforcement platform which is
the big-ass gun that shoots down
absolutely everything that tries to get
in the planet so we're going to just
leave that live for now it would be
super awesome to be able to zip back up
to the top knowing that I could go right
to that place I could even have a cat
you'll beach side based on that island
right by my big-ass gun after i
reprogram it for my purposes and not to
shoot me as I try to leave and then I
could be king of this planet that I hate
oh I could be lord of the oceans that
I'm terrified of wouldn't that be just
wonderful oh I can't thrust wanna none
water I don't know why I thought I would
be able to but anyway I've got some
comments here that I I mean the read
first one is George East who said
markiplier episode 1 I hate the ocean
and the ocean I hate the ocean and then
Marcus markiplier now rams sea dragon
with submarine oh man
if that didn't present perspective was
that the changes that I've been through
this horror hill that is subnautica and
I don't know what will
so now that have gone in here akka too
so I don't know if there's anything else
in this area to explore there was that
case where I flew up before but I don't
know if that actually leads anywhere for
the month we'll check it out where I go
deeper in oh oh we must lead up to
another entrance in here at least that's
what I think it would be oh yeah you're
all but Dobby oh but ok oh where do you
lead please tell me you lead out and not
to another horrible monstrosity that I
don't want to say
I gather data concerning can I please
get back to big box Barry I don't feel
safe out by myself
I'm getting farther away from him going
Oh what is this hello
Kazuki give me up you and my first thing
I can't tell perfect
oh okay it's another way in okay good
all right so we're all where is the sea
dragon sea dragons got to be around okay
gotta make it back mr. Pfister whoa hey
your call camera save now all right you
want to go bro huh you want to go I'll
go apparently no I won't
I won't oh there we go are you want to
go huh all right fine you want to be
like that I'll go with you I'll go a few
places we go I'll go mano-a-mano with
you
yeah I just clawed my way back from the
death [ __ ] I had a tough time it's on
my sable it's gonna load so who's gonna
have to fight 20 hours to get back to
you which I'm gonna fight I've got a
plan for you we work for the warper it
might work for you mist okay miss miss
miss I'm gonna come back down good good
good be back get me back oh you'd be
back to be back back just be back Oh get
me back okay where'd he go way over
there well that's ominous some scary
looking okay y'all come back here buddy
hey I'm gonna grind the [ __ ] out of you
my grand the [ __ ] out of you I'm gonna
grow old hey that's scary alright I'm
gonna grind the [ __ ] out of you oh [ __ ]
you can't grip up to him okay he's got
he's intangible you can't actually touch
him
that's here fine okay so you're gonna
pop out an out and wrap me up and one go
yeah I'm gonna do this I know I'm stupid
also able to rely sure a mark this area
terrifies me and scares the [ __ ] out of
me
I'm most likely going to Diamond imma
live here
rest in peace mark recipes Oh all right
and then Zephyrs Aurore iam said
something similar bad idea to build the
base where the sea dragon lived there
might be a 5.2 percent chances attack
them I see your base of yours and
destroy it
of course thermal reactor handy down
there and here isn't food but still a
bad idea
just like trying to beat the [ __ ] out of
this [ __ ] dragon with my bare hands
or my bare mr. Pfister hand my bare fist
oh yeah you scream a lot get off of me
is if you're tough I bet the sea dragons
gonna be tough too that's all right I'm
just trying to make my way back to my
[ __ ]
next time I know yeah no no no no okay
I'm almost back in ah [ __ ] I got oh oh
oh [ __ ] you want to go oh I got him I
got him oh [ __ ] you I got him I don't
know if I got him I don't know where I'm
going oh god I think I got him holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] oh my god it's keep ground
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh this is a bad idea
oh my god oh I have no idea what's
happening right now the game doesn't
even know how to handle it holy [ __ ] -
got him oh I lost the help call me not
being let me skated around on the ground
huh [ __ ] dude holy [ __ ]
well flush why am I doing this
Oh God well [ __ ] here we go gosh he's
trying to give me oh god oh god I'm
grinding them holy [ __ ]
I'm not gonna let go stay I'm gonna let
go after I come this big fish this real
big fish oh holy [ __ ] okay I I don't
even know he's gonna drag me into the
wall there alright if I can just get
make a few passes on this ah we have the
contact yeah dude oh boy oh boy this
terrible idea is the worst idea I've
ever had how far away am i from my oh
good I'm not too far away
uh-oh watch those fireballs everybody
you did you get you did you did you get
you yeah yeah you want some yeah you
can't handle me
do I sound confident oh my god oh my god
he's hitting me somehow I think it's
this is fin just me bouncing off of his
fins damaging me unless it's like the
residual heat from all the like lava
rock city swallows that's how he's able
to fit him if you didn't know fun fact
about the sea dragon oh [ __ ]
I feel like Captain Ahab
I'm grinding grinding grinding grinding
whoa whoa whoa what's happening where am
I
whoa where am I I think you tried to eat
me holy [ __ ] I was in his mouth for a
second there
Ron dry grind grind kick ground kick
ground kick ground get crunch whoa oh I
thought I killed him for a second there
oh okay oh [ __ ] who's gonna die first me
or him
aah Oh God that's in the mouth that is
definitely in the mouth
holy [ __ ] oh my god can you kill him I
have no idea I got to go back for repair
soon if I can go back at all
ah [ __ ] gotta go back for repairs and
water oh okay all right one last pass
and then I'm gonna get out of here I
can't kill him now I don't think I ever
will
God he keeps talking me awake so far or
you know what I'm gonna bail I'm in
nineteen percent Oh I'm drifting very
far do not come back for me I think we
did equal damage to both of us that's
terrifying
[ __ ] give me back my [ __ ] Barry
please welcome me in the bosom ah [ __ ]
ray nedda
ah [ __ ] ah got into those terrifying you
yes okay get back in please
he's um get back in little more little
more
come on please I'm right here come on
there okay there we go holy [ __ ] system
online holy [ __ ] huh oh my god
of harrowing fish I'm not okay it's all
kind of not okay
Oh huh did you save here oh man oh why
did I do that why did I do that I have
no idea why did that I have no idea why
I did that
I have no goddamn idea I have no idea
huh [ __ ] all right so getting my
bearings getting a drink of water that's
terrifying
but anyway so I've got one more comment
to read thank you kim sung-soo who gave
a huge list of stuff for me from
notifying me which video wasn't in my
playlist to talking about thermometers
uh you can pick up pink floaters and you
can release them near other creatures
and they will home in on them and take
them away so I'm wondering what will
happen if I get enough floaters and
attach it to the sea dragon or any other
creature man and then talking about a
whole bunch of other stuff things that
I've missed in the past little tips I've
pinned that common to the last to the
last um let last video that I did and in
the future every comment that I get I'm
just going to pin so those who if I
can't build a freaking Locker then I'm
going to be able to um at least
recognize those comments in some way so
that will be the future I'll still make
lockers when I can and have the titanium
for them but if I can't I'll pin the
comments okay alright I'm good I'm good
I'm good so long story short there's no
titanium down here and I've already
committed to not cheating so I'm not
going to be able to build a base right
now that doesn't mean that I won't try
to do that in the future it just means
that if I were to do that I will have to
bring down an umpteen million amount of
titanium and all the other building
materials that I'm
need gonna take a while but hopefully
it'll be worth it I'm not an aggressive
said I don't know why I'm standing just
still here oh god damn it
Larry kid or Lester kid off my goddamn
clothes I'm draining my frickin power
like that
get off enough enough I know I've
probably got more elsewhere how that
hurts a lot move come close all right
I'm just checking to see if there's more
fish whatever I'm seeing one now we're
good okay yes he's done happy we got one
floating in gonna move get out of here
Lester's coming back okay all right
we're out of here okay we're gonna get
out of here
and what we're going to do is we're
going to try to find where the the alien
containment is or a way out whichever
way we go first
I have no idea where we are in relation
to where we were so I'm just gonna pick
a direction go that way and hopefully I
don't know hopefully reach something
that I need soon huh right I'm not okay
I don't know why I'm not okay after that
I mean in all honesty I don't know
that's really stupid of me to do but
also freaking awesome to be able to do I
didn't even know if that was gonna work
and I'd given up on it melts and he pops
out nowhere and I thought oh he's after
me oh hi oh he's mad he wants round to
you now Ram you at the seamoth or the
Cyclops big box Bear gonna slam into you
and you're not gonna like it I don't
know if that's gonna hurt you at all I
don't know I don't even know if it can
be killed
oh can it do you guys know do you guys
know if the sea dragon can be killed
because I bet it if it's able to beat
the [ __ ] out of an entire alien
containment facility and then that's
what kills it through only severe head
trauma and only after it it brings down
the whole facility like what am I going
to do to it
I gonna do ramming into that thing very
little that's for sure okay but anyway
I'm good we're all good I'm calm we're
getting back into it we're making a nice
relaxing feline tail between our legs
sprint out of here and then we're going
in finding something else or maybe not
because where the heck is this okay that
might be the way I came in or it might
be the way deeper in I have no idea so
I'm just gonna venture down this way try
to see if I can drop lower I think this
might be the way I came in
from I don't know though hey all fricken
mystery down here and I can't see
anything with all this freaking blue
I don't like to look at that I don't
like to look at it but I'm gonna explore
yeah I'm gonna repair mr. Pfister oh no
I don't have batter he's goddamn it I
need to put I need to put my batteries
in there I need to make a battery okay
hang on I got the recipe for making our
using copper is that all I need
that's amazing I'll have a perma battery
I've got copper I've got lots of copper
oh okay all right good all right so if I
make look if I make I don't know why I'm
still fluffing if I make an ion battery
and then I don't have silicon because
I'm pretty sure to make silicon you need
either the creepvine something I forget
what they've changed it to recently yeah
you need seed clusters so I don't have
that down here but I can at least make
the battery I can make two of those and
then I'll be able to power actually I
need one for pretty much everything I
have how many island crystals do I have
to spare in total oh I've got a lot okay
I'm going to put these all in one
location I'm not going to use them all
obviously but the ideal is to turn all
the battery-powered devices that I have
into batteries and at least save six of
those for my like Cyclops to eventually
change out the power cells into ion
cells which would be the ideal cuz I
would that would help out the most but
this is at low battery so if I just pop
that in there and then I'm pretty sure
that these are all going to be these are
all going to be I'm gonna make one more
for my builder these are all going to be
good in terms of like lasting longer and
also they can be recharged I'm pretty
sure I'm not 100% sure on that but I I
would be surprised if you couldn't
recharge these incredibly valuable very
rare ion batteries so I'm just gonna do
that and now come on come on now
Oh apparently the Builder can't use the
ion power source oh that's
Dhar huh maybe the scanner can know why
is that this can yeah oh that's bizarre
I guess only the high-powered things can
ooh that means I can finally make a see
glide again it cannot suck oh you can go
back and get my seagull ID if I ever get
out of this hellhole but that's that's
good okay all right anyway so I'll stop
freaking out about that so I've got I'll
put all the ion stuff in one storage
Jonas grab will have that so was red has
miscellaneous stuff common Coral for
water which I don't need right now I can
just eat some fruit I think okay let's
repair you with my superpower
oh man that goes down real toy [ __ ]
hey hey goddamn it get off him BAM
sorry yeah thanks Sheriff who are you
dear preparing him he needs a break give
him a goddamn breather okay so anyway so
I'm going to take this thing down I
don't even know if there's a hole down
there to really go deep into so I'm just
assuming that this is uh this is just a
normal not too terrible hole yeah I just
kind of want to explore and also take an
opportunity to repair also it's not that
hot down here why is it not roasting Lee
hot because that's normally a thing that
happens when I'm and I'm a down here I'm
usually dying from the heat but
apparently right now I am NOT I don't
know when that happened I mean I haven't
modified my suit so this must be
generally a colder area oh there's
mushrooms down here well that's weird
Who am I why are there mushrooms down
here are there other materials oh god
damn it
Lester get off my goddamn boat and that
might explain why it's cooler over here
because it is going towards the the
cooler location okay yeah this is
definitely going up okay so this is the
way I came
100% because I think it just that's
where it just goes straight up and that
means I can go back down and that
explains why the mushrooms are there so
the mushrooms are like a transitional
thing between this and the Lost River at
least that tree area so if I go this way
and then go straight across to the other
side of where the the thermal generator
power plant is and hopefully I'll find
another way to go even deeper it might
be in that cave it might be through that
cave I am not 100% sure that that cave
didn't lead deeper I just didn't get a
chance to explore cuz mr. Fisher was
about to die and then mr. Custer did die
and then what the [ __ ] was that
what [ __ ] with that
I think you shocked that guy's really
draining my power fine fine fine fine
I'm going to get them off
fine fine fine fine fine fine fine fine
fine hey come on oh god I've got a lot
of them on here get off okay
oh my god cuz I just sitting there
repairing get off huh yeah hey [ __ ] you
get off and off anymore you [ __ ] on
there there's so many get off my boat
goddammit that I hit you one go oh there
we go okay get off yeah get off okay I
hope none of them got back on after I
beat them off let's just get out of here
goddamnit that was the sound of you
snack tin on there isn't it [ __ ] hell
these [ __ ] [ __ ] stop it now that
you fricking [ __ ] they just pop
right back on get off there we go get
off I'll kill you alright let me just go
before I cuz I can't I can't just job
god they're right back on frickin dick
brick you and Frick a dick oh man
there's an issue okay there's the plan
okay
so then it might actually mean that the
straight-across movement was the king
and if that was where the cave was and
maybe the cave is in fact where I'm
supposed to go
that that is it that's it this is right
there tight quarters in here real tight
might actually not be a cave so this
might be a formation that looks cave
like ah ignoring my booping warnings
yeah this might not be a cave it might
just be some archways that seem to lead
me down a bit farther yeah yeah yeah
this is this isn't what I was looking
for God how am I gonna back out of here
let's get out this way uh too small
I can't fat Frank oh [ __ ] ah god damn it
okay
alright we're fine okay so anyway this
wasn't where I was supposed to go so
I'll figure out where to go in the next
episode I uh I've gotten myself in some
trouble and I've gotten myself out of
some trouble and all I need to know
where the hell I'm going next so I'm
gonna find that very soon one more
update as we go and then eventually
long-term plans build a base down here
fly [ __ ] dragon kind of like it will be
a Captain Ahab type situation with my
white whales that I'm going to beat to
death with my bear mr. Pfister well
we'll see when that happens - thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know how i'm doing the comments below
and give me supervisor encouragement to
make a joke that's all i really good to
know
thanks as always i'll see you in the
next video bye bye
[Music]